oh man I tell you parenting is no joke
[Applause]
[Music]
night terrors I wasn't sure what I was
gonna think of this one
going back in because my memory of this
one has always been that it's just kind
of an episode that's there and having
watched it I still kind of feel that
it's an episode that's there so this is
the one that opens with one of the best
hooks ever and Doctor Who as far as I'm
concerned the idea that a child is so
scared that his desperate plea for help
resonates all the way to the TARDIS
shows up on the psychic paper and the
doctor makes a house call I love that I
love that because that plays into the
more fairytale elements of Doctor Who
that the show is capable of that I don't
necessarily think should be the
overriding approach of the show but when
they get played up every now and then
they tend to make me smile and Matt
Smith had during his run some great sort
of fairytale moments I mean the very
beginning of his run with the idea that
as far as Amelia is concerned he's her
imaginary friend as a child who came
back that's very fairy tale and this
opening in this hook this cold open very
fairy tale in a way that I feel works
and fits within Doctor Who and then we
actually get the story itself and it's
fine there's some neat elements there's
some cool aspects but it's just kind of
they're part of it unfortunately is we
are slightly dependent on a child actor
and all due respect to child actors
acting is not easy no matter what age
you are but good child actors are rare
good child actors for TV are even
raela and that's a big part of why when
you have kids and prominent roles
they're just there to be cute or
precocious and they're not expected to
carry more weight than that and so
because this kid has to be terrified and
super scared he doesn't do a horrible
job selling it but I think for what they
could have realistically expected a
child actor to be capable of doing they
leaned on him a little too much I think
the expectations for him as a as a young
actor were a little higher than they
should have been cuz they shouldn't have
expected to find a young actor who's
gonna deliver that level good the level
that would have been needed to really
elevate his part in the story the whole
idea of the things he's scared of being
put in the cupboard is an odd one and
honestly almost feels like they're
trying to do fear her but Bette actually
in many ways this feels like taking
another crack at the fundamental kernel
of fear her and not have it just suck
and it doesn't it's better than fear but
maybe it's a kernel they should not
bother trying anymore because fear her
just had nothing good in it
like at all and this while it's fine I
feel like this whole concept of a child
that has some sort of alien thing going
on around them and their their fears are
impacting the world around them I feel
like this is this it feels like the best
doctor who's gonna do that concept so
let's leave it alone at this point the
the thing with the dollhouse it's kind
of neat at first you know when Amy and
Rory end up in there and they realize
everything's fake the food is wood the
clock doesn't have actual hands on it
they're just painted on that's actually
kind of cool and kind of creepy and I
wish it's an idea that had been in
something else because it's just sort of
basically there to serve as a standard
haunted house ish set for them to wander
around in and similarly the dolls are
buried
insert creepy semi faceless monster here
I know they creep some people out
severely but I think that only happens
if you have some sort of inherent
creeped out thing around dolls which I
don't it reminds me of what I said about
the movie it which is that if you don't
have an inherent fear of clowns I don't
actually think it's that scary because
they're banking on it just automatically
being creepy and not doing the extra
work to make it creepy
I felt that about the clown and it I
feel that about the dolls in this so
that doesn't make the dolls bad it just
makes them unexceptional and that's kind
of the thing across the board with this
whole episode and I especially feel that
given we're coming off of a story of
dealing with Amy and Rory becoming
parents losing their daughter finding
her again but having missed out on
knowingly raising her I feel like there
should have been that connection made to
that between that and the difficulty
that this father is having raising a
child because he's in over his head and
he doesn't know how to deal with it
which as a parent yeah that's a standard
operating mode pretty much I don't know
what I'm doing somebody help less you
want a secret nobody knows what's going
on anymore than you do so anyways I feel
like it's a really missed opportunity
that there wasn't a connection drawn
there I almost feel like in some ways at
the very least Amy if not both of Amy
and Rory should have been present for
the father's realizations for his fears
for his kind of freaking out and his
panic so that they could by proxy get a
taste of elements of parenting they
never had you'd have to completely
rebuild the episode on how to do that
because the narrative as it stands just
forcibly removes Amy and Rory from the
story and literally sticks them in the
cupboard
this story does to Amy and Rory what
let's kill Hitler did Hitler just stick
him in the cupboard we'll deal with him
later
but I really feel like there should have
been something done with that the
performance of the Father is very good
he's incredibly relatable incredibly
human he does a great job of letting out
the exasperation that you feel as a
parent where you're like there has to be
a better way to do this I must be doing
something wrong but you also don't know
what would be better or if doing
something different would make it worse
or if maybe you shouldn't even be
bothering am I so bad at this that I
shouldn't even be parenting this child
those are legitimate feelings and fears
that as a parent you're gonna have at
some point he doesn't a really good job
at selling them I was quite impressed
with that Matt Smith give us a good
performance and he has some great lines
of great turns in terms of his mood and
his approach to things his sort of
bouncing between Oh everything will be
fine I'm an expert too oh my god the
stuff in that cupboard is real do not
open that cupboard we can't do that we
need to open the cupboard like that
jumping back and forth with him Matt
Smith does really well he does the
doctor turning on a dime possibly better
than any other doctor or at the very
least he's in the upper echelon of the
ones who do that those quick mood shifts
all he's really good at it but overall
it's it's just kind of there and the
other thing is the reveal that the boy
himself effectively is an alien I have
mixed feelings on the first is that the
reveal of it is kind of cool in terms of
the execution of the father learning
that of him in a moment of emotional
exasperation just bursting out something
that he's always known but has kind of
been filtered out of his brain she can't
have kids and then suddenly realising
what that means
for the situation he now finds himself
in that was really well handled as far
as the doing that reveal doing that turn
but overall here's that here's the thing
that annoys me about that sort of twist
it's not bad and it doesn't wreck the
narrative or anything but I also don't
think it adds anything to it either I
don't think that there's anything you
gain out of the kid himself being the
source of the events going on that it
wouldn't that wasn't already the case
when we presumed the kid was simply
being affected by something that was
causing everything to go on I mean his
fears is the root is the root of
everything no matter what having him not
even be human doesn't other than just
sort of the coolness of the reveal
moment it doesn't add anything it
doesn't reframe enough of the story it's
just a twist so that there's a twist it
kind of marks time which makes it
harmless I suppose but also unnecessary
so yeah that's kind of where I am on
night terrors it's fine yeah it's fine
it's not one a god I haven't read
watched it in years and I can't imagine
I'll rewatch it again anytime soon
because it's just kind of there and it
works so bad doesn't annoy me there's
nothing about it that's like fundamental
Oh John why would they do that but just
a lot of yeah although bonus it's got a
bulldog bulldogs so you know
yay for Bernhard so that's night terrors
what are your thoughts on it whatever
they are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it you'll also
find out in the description a PayPal tip
jar if you feel like donating a little
bit of support my way
there's also patreon if you feel like
contributing on a more regular basis
plus you know usual stuff like subscribe
share this video but you don't have to
do any of it I'm not gonna tell you what
to do I'm not your dad because at the
end of the day you're the council I'm
just running the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]